we spent a good deal of time on the idea
of a null space what i'm going to do in
this video is introduce you to a new
type of space that can be defined around
a matrix it's called a column space
column space and you could probably
guess what it means just based on what
it's called but let's say i have some
matrix a
let's say it's an m by n
matrix so i can write my matrix a and
we've seen this multiple times i can
write it as a collection of column
vectors so this first one
second one and i'll have n of them how
do i know that they i have n of them
because i have n
columns
and each of these column vectors are
going to have how many components so v1
v2
all the way to vn well they had this
matrix has m rows right so each of these
guys are going to have m components so
they're all
members of r
m
so the column space is defined as all of
the possible linear combinations of
these column vectors
so the column space
of a this is my matrix a
the column space of that is all the
linear combinations of these column
vectors what's all of the linear
combinations of a set of vectors it's
the span
it's the span
of those vectors so it's a span of
vector 1
vector 2
all the way
to vector n
and we've done it before when we first
talked about span and subspaces but it's
pretty easy to show that the span of any
set of vectors is a legitimate subspace
it definitely contains the zero vector
if you multiply all of these guys by
zero which is a valid linear combination
added up you'll see that it contains the
zero vector if
let's say that
let's say i have some vector a
that is a member of
that's a member of we'll say it's a
member of the column space of a
that means it can be represented as some
linear combination so a is equal to you
know c1 times vector 1 plus c2 times
vector 2 all the way to c n
times vector n
now the question is is this closed under
multiplication is if i multiply a times
some new
let me call it let me say i multiply it
times some scalar s
i'm just picking a random letter so s
times a is this in my span
well s times a would be equal to s
c 1 v 1 plus s
c 2
v 2 all the way to s
c n
v n which is once again just a linear
combination of these column vectors so
this s a
would clearly be a member of the column
space
of a and then finally to make sure it's
a valid subspace and this actually
doesn't apply just to column spaces this
applies to any span this is actually a
review of what we've done in the past we
just have to make sure it's closed under
addition so let's say a is a member of
our column space let's say b is also a
member of our column space
or our span of all of these column
vectors then
b could be rewritten could be written as
i don't know let me say b1 times v1 plus
b2 times v2 all the way to bn times vn
and my question is is a
plus b
is a plus b a member of our
of our span of our column space the span
of these vectors
well sure what's a plus b a plus b
a plus b is equal to
c1
plus b1
times v1
times v1 plus c2 plus b2 times v2
right i'm just literally adding this
term to that term to get that term this
term to this term to get this term and
then it goes all the way to
vn plus cn
times vn which is clearly just another
linear combination of these guys so this
guy is definitely within the span so the
span of and and this what i just did it
doesn't have to be unique to a matrix i
mean a matrix is just really just a way
of writing a set of column vectors so
this applies to any span so this is
clearly a valid subspace
so the column space of a is clearly a
valid
subspace now let's think about other
ways we can interpret this notion of a
column space let's think about it in
terms of
let's let's think of it in terms of the
expression
let me get a good color if i were to
multiply
my
let's think about this
let's think about the set
of all the values of if i take
my m by n matrix a and i multiply it by
any m any vector x
where
where x
where x is a member of remember x has to
be a member of r n it has to have n
components in order for this
multiplication to be well defined
so x has to be a member of rn
let's think about what this means this
is the set if this says look i can take
any member any n component vector and
multiply it by a and i care about all of
the possible products that this could
equal all the possible values of ax when
i can pick and choose any possible x
from rn let's think about what that
means
ax
ax if i write a like that and if i write
x like this
and let me write it a little bit better
let me write x like this x1 x2
all the way to xn
what is ax
well ax could be rewritten as x1 and
we've seen this before
ax
is equal to
x1
times
v1
plus
x2
times
v2
all the way to
plus all the way to plus xn
times
vn
right we've seen this multiple times
this comes out of our definition of
matrix vector products now if ax is
equal to this
if ax is equal to this and i can i'm
essentially saying that i can pick any
vector x and rn i'm saying that i can
pick all possible values of the entries
here all possible real values and all
possible combinations of them
so what is this equal to what is the set
of all possible
so i could rewrite this statement here
as the set of all possible x1
v1
plus x2
v2
all the way to xn
vn
where
x1
x2 all the way to xn are a member of the
real numbers that's all i'm saying here
this statement is equivalent of this
when i say that x the vector x can be
any member of rn i'm saying that it's
components can be any members of the
real numbers so if i just take the set
of all of the essentially the
combinations of these column vectors
where they're real numbers where were
there where their coefficients are
members of of of the real numbers what
am i doing this is all the possible
linear combinations of the column
vectors of a so this is equal to
the span
sorry well it equals the span of v1 v2
all the way to vn
which is the same thing
which is the same exact same thing as
the column space of a so the column
space of a you could say hey what what
are all of the possible vectors or the
set of all vectors i can create by
taking linear combinations of these guys
or the span of these guys or you can
view it as what are all of the possible
values that a x can take on if x is a
member of rn
so let's think about it this way
let me let's say that
i were to tell you that a
that i need to solve the equation a x
a x is equal to
let me say well the convention is to
write a b there but let me put a special
b there let me put b
1.
let's say that i need to solve this
equation ax is equal to b1 and then i
were to tell you let's say that i were
to figure out the column space of a and
i say
b1
not
is not a member
of the column space of a
then what does that tell me that tells
me that this
this right here can never take on the
value b1 right because all of the values
that this can take on is the column
space of a so if b1 is not in this it
means that this cannot take on the value
of b1 so this would imply
this would imply that this equation
we're trying to set up ax is equal to b1
has no solution
has no solution if it had a solution
if it had some solution so let's say
that ax
equals
b2 so let's say ax equals b2 has
at least one solution has at least
one
solution
what does this mean
well that means that this
for a particular x or maybe for many
different x's you can definitely achieve
this value right for there are some x's
when you multiply it by a you definitely
are able to get this value so this
implies that b2
is definitely a member of the column
space
of a some of this stuff on some level
it's almost obvious this comes out of
the definition of the column space the
column space is all of the linear
combinations of the column vectors which
another interpretation is all of the
values that ax can take on so if i try
to set ax to some value that it can't
take on clearly i'm not going to have
some solution if i set ax
if i am able to find if i am able to
find a solution i might if i am able to
find some x value where a x is equal to
b 2 then b 2 definitely is one of the
values that ax can take on
anyway i think i'll leave you there now
that you have at least a a kind of
abstract understanding of what a column
space is in the next couple of videos
i'm going to try to bring everything
together what we know about column
spaces and null spaces and whatever else
to kind of understand a matrix and a
matrix vector product from every
possible direction